a
um
2 8 23. all right I'm gonna
oh yes let's let's pledge thank you
please join with me in a pledge to our
foreign
[Music]
going to start on the early bills well
that's
I'll spill while first up is House Bill
requiring the director of the division
of archives and Records management to
compile and maintain a list of public
monuments
foreign
Mr chair
yes
um I have an amendment to that bill
um it was it was submitted uh personally
I have the bill
oh okay okay so um I move ought to pass
on uh House Bill one seven on I'm sorry
a lot of emotion on the floor up to
about to pass
is there a second
second by representative darn
Darby
and uh you wish to speak on your motion
well I'd like to present an amendment to
that Mo to that bill okay we'll accept
I'll accept the amendment okay thank you
and I believe that amendment was one
that you distributed to the committee I
have not distributed any met uh okay
if you recall during the public hearing
the
um Prime sponsor's intent of the bill
was to have compiled a list of Monument
historical resources and monuments in
the state
and he initially uh delegated that
responsibility to
um
the archives and Records management
department but after further discussion
with
um the division of historical resources
that's a much more appropriate place for
it that also would not have a fiscal
note they could easily absorb that
responsibility as the Director mentioned
during the public hearing or I think
maybe it was in a letter we received so
this amendment
um aligns the responsibility of
compiling that record to the appropriate
agency without any additional cost so
that's why I I support and bring forth
oh women
uh we uh we have to vote on the on the
amendment first come on uh but is
so uh on the
you you just your test you uh the
I need a sec you're presenting the
amendment
I uh is there a you if you second the
amendment executive representative the
Darby for seconds gotta gotta forgive me
it's only been this is our first one
and I'm and I'm old I forget things
uh
on the amendment I could I actually I
could either we could we have a choice I
could either take it I could take it by
affirmation or if I hand or uh let's
just call the
very good
thank you Mr chair uh representative
harb
yes
representative Connors
representative Horgan the clerk votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf
yes
representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly
yes representative Dunn yes
representative Veil yes
representative wrong
yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative Hoyt yes
representative Lamontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan
yes
representative renzulu yes it's 20 gays
no Nays motion passes all right
yeah now the the motion on the floor is
ought to pass as amended you wish to
speak to your motion
um I think everything I said about the
value of this amendment and
um and and now the amended bill
um I think I said enough but I would
just like to remind we did have
testimony from our retired social
studies teacher who said that this is
really going to be a resource for
foreign
sure yes please
okay
um what oh yes here we go
um
the
regarding what representative rung said
um the testimony we heard was that based
on the amendment it there will be no
cost associated with this it will help
both students high school students for
example competing in
um uh in a comp an Internet Interstate
competition and it will also help to
raise awareness really across the state
so
good
I would like to speak on the uh on the
motion
uh
it's my feeling
that this bill though I support the bill
I believe the bill needs to be retained
in order to discuss some important
things relative to the builds remember
we did not get any testimony
from Mr from
Mr Wilson
uh who was Sue he sent a letter but
there was little there were questions
and that in my mind that I would I need
answered before I will I would vote for
this uh he said it's there's something
about once this being uh
uh
this bill the this once every 10 years
does he get the uh his department has to
do that uh has to do this survey
there's no estimate of the time of work
because he started uh when does he start
when does the 10 years start and when
does it end does it end right after the
there's a start right after the 10-year
ends as he started Acworth and go to uh
uh go to Windsor or go to will win them
uh what's the scope of this bill
uh how how many monuments or markers are
uh I was going to have to have to is he
going to have to look at
I have no clue do you
uh this uh is it just monuments and
markers about cannons there's a lot of
cannons in town
and my my town has uh has at least two
or I know Nashville has at least four
uh Concord has more cannons than the
uh then well we won't say that uh any uh
the other how is the involvement with
the locals
the local people what if the locals say
we don't want you here get out of here
uh
what there's there's just too many
uh questions unanswered and we really do
need to hear from the the
the division that's going to be doing
the work and how he's he's scheduling it
uh this bill is a uh is a
uh an early bill it may not be an early
bill but he says it's not going to
because he says it's uh that he's going
to do it
for uh for no money
or no additional money
that's not our that's not our call I
think there's real we really need to
spend the time
uh so to to listen to see this to
to discuss this bill and to re to retain
it and then pass it at a later date
after retention
other than that I I will be voting no
and if the if the no
uh if
you'd be if the motion to retain fails
then I will ask for a motion
to Ideal
yes
Mr chair yes I could probably ask the
clerk this question but in my notes Mr
Wilson did testify at the public hearing
and he did support it and he said it
would be a very easy task for his uh
division to assume no he sent a letter
and I read the letter
oh okay you read the letter into the
record yes okay thank you
representative wolf thank you Mr
chairman
um
I think this is just too broad it
includes physical markers of a
historical event or geographical sites
of historical or cultural significance
what is that if there's a piece of land
outside a meeting house that somebody
walks through we have to inventory that
there's it's just so broad here anything
of a physical marker or a historical
event of individuals or geographical
sites I think it's much too broad I
I'll go along with retaining but I think
that there's just too much in here that
somebody will be out there from day one
for the next 10 years
recording things and starting all over
again
so I I'm opposed to the bill
but we'll accept retention if that's the
representative Vale
um
now during the hearing we did hear from
several of the representatives
um and where we're talking here about
the division of historical resources
don't they have rulemaking authority
about how these
would be inventoried and
how often that they would keep this up
to date
what I what I see here is that well what
I see in my own town is that we we work
on
um
our historical resources but we don't
necessarily have a government body
overlooking overseeing that and I'm not
sure that some of the concerns with this
bill actually belong in statute where we
know that the division of historical
Resources Director has a rule making
Authority
if that is the case and so I would be
or any other
is there any other uh anyone else who
Darby thank you uh Mr chair now I just
would like to point out um from the
amendment that um it does say work with
local communities so
um as I I read the bill it's not that
the um the
division of historical resources
believes that they have to individually
account for each Monument independently
but they'll work with the local
resources
um you know the local communities in
particular to inventory those
um
therefore I
I I think it is clear in terms of uh the
scope that's being collected
thank you
anyone else wish to speak for a first
time
seeing none for a second time
thank you Mr chair
I did want to mention also that there's
really no fiscal impact involved with
this bill so although has a financial
note it doesn't
really need financing and that's
something that we'll be commenting on as
we send it along
um and that's all I had to say for now
thank you
is there anyone else versus to speak
for a second time thank you just just
quickly
I mean I don't think this should even be
a contentious bill I mean it's what it
is it's putting in statute that the
division of historical resources has to
compile a list of historical resources
anyone else wish to speak so there we go
Motion
the court please call the roll
yes thank you Mr chair Representative
harb no
representative Connors no
representative Horrigan no
other Quotes no representative Healy no
representative wolf no representative
McHugh no representative Donnelly no
representative Don no representative
Vale
yes
representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes
representative Hoyt yes representative
Lamontagne yes representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan
yes
representative
no
representative Barb
representative heart would you uh Mr
chairman I'd like to make a motion to
retain uh this bill 194 FM yes so we can
would you like to speak
representative Dale
would you like to speak um
on your motion thank you Mr chair just
very briefly uh I'm not against the
concept of uh our people knowing where
it is but for some of the reasons
mentioned I think this bill can be made
better and I'd like to retain it so that
we can work on it thank you
you like to speak on your second thank
you Mr chair
I think it's I think at this point
because we it's we have 10 to 10 that
retaining it is is a good idea
especially if not everyone is
comfortable with the language
when I look at the language and and on
the amendment with Part B on line 14 it
says once every 10 years the director
shall work with local communities and
what I understand in my own town and may
not be an example of every town is that
people are keeping an inventory of
what's going on ongoingly and I see this
as more of something of a Reconciliation
I think that a lot of these monuments
and places of historical significance in
New Hampshire already are recorded and
they're being they are
um being taken care of so I do think
that we should retain it and make
everyone comfortable with the language
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
the motion to retain
would that be retaining the motion as
amended
hey representative harb yes
representative Connors yeah
representative Morgan yes Mr Butz yes
representative Healy
yes representative wolf
yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale
yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative Hoyt yes representative
LaMontagne yes representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative Zulu
yes
is the bill is weak uh house bill
uh uh no retained retention is not going
uh
mistaken next next one is
two one two yeah I'll spill we'll open
this session on House Bill
hearing a house bill 212.
uh representative run
thank you Mr chair I move ought to pass
you'll have a second
a second
seconded by
representative Dunn
we wish to speak to uh
your motion yes thank you Mr Cherry will
um House Bill 212 came out as a result
of discussions with the HB 737 pfas
Commission
what we did was there were three
recommendations made in our annual
report to the governor and Senate
President and speaker of the house after
discussions with Des we bundled those
recommendations into house bill 212 and
worked with Des on the language to make
sure that it was technically accurate
and and that it meant the intent of the
commission what this bill does is it
adds some money into an existing pfas
remediation fund allowing that fund to
assume broader
to address broader issues such as the
increased need for testing scientific
investigation and any moderation that
needs to occur if and when the EPA
issues maximum contaminant levels for
pfas at the federal level
um as such the the name of that fund has
been changed in this bill to pfas
response fund
um we all know that pfas is a major
issue in Southern New Hampshire and In
Pockets of other states and we need to
ensure that our Environmental Services
department is well equipped and
resourced in order to address those
you wish to speak to your second
I'll just this spill is something that
is going to help a lot of people is a
good thing and I think we should
OTP
but perhaps representative Vale
thank you Mr chair
when we met earlier on this bill
um we just wanted to be
um one of the things that we spoke about
was that um there's concerns over the
testing costs
but when we discussed that we were able
to just the priority of the bill is so
important and with pfas causing cancer
and causing um
a lot of different things that will
really go wrong
with your finances and with everything
that you need to do once you find out
that your water is contaminated
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
to the bill
is
seeing none a motion of
ought to pass and 212 will the clerk
please call the roll
thank you Mr chair representative harb
yes
representative Connors yes
representative Oregon yes clerk votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative Lamontagne
yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan Yes representative renzulu
yes
in 20 20 years
20 years zero Nays bill
uh well it was just I said I was going
to go right along but to uh
uh onto I was going to do early Bills
first
okay
yeah
uh
do I uh will I hear them do I hear a
motion Mr chairman
I'd like to make a motion to retain this
bill
um
I'll speak to it after
emotionally motion for retain do I hear
second
by representative Horgan we used to
speak to your uh oh sure thank you Mr
chair
um as was noted uh the Des uh as a
result of a bill last year is working on
an extensive plan concerning
cyanobacteria mitigation and we expect
that plan will be coming out this
November so I'd like to retain this bill
and then we'll have that plan and we can
review it and make the appropriate
changes if necessary to the proposed
representative Horgan you wish to speak
to your second
no additional comments thank you Mr
chairman
thank you anyone else wish to speak to
the bill of kings of the motion
representative rock thank you Mr chair I
strongly oppose the motion to retain uh
for several reasons one is that
cyanobacteria is an extremely serious
issue in New Hampshire it gets worse
every year we don't do anything this
money would cover existing projects that
have been identified but that don't have
funding that have already been prepared
through EPA approved watershed
management plans
also by retaining it we lose the ability
of securing the funding in the second
year so essentially retaining it is
killing it
Des is
you know they spoke to this they said
it's a worthwhile if you read the
commissioner's letter it's a very
worthwhile bill you will see that I've
passed around I have an amendment which
if the retained most fails I would like
to speak to the amendment which
addresses a lot of the issues that were
brought up during the public hearing not
that there were many there were very
very few if I have the ability of the
retained motion fails there there is
people there are people here from Des
who would be willing to speak to this
representative
thank you Mr chair
I also rise in part of the bill
um and the motion to ought to pass I
with as amended I am
really think this is a serious problem
and we've been told that this will cost
billions of dollars and it affects our
Lakes Region it is really important for
us to protect the environment and to
protect the species that we're trying to
return to the lake such as loons when we
go through almost all of these bills
that we've done so far this year it is
really clear to me that cyanobacteria
can make most of our work Moot and it
will make it very much harder to
sustain the Lakes Region and the
recreation we had testimony that um like
correct me if I'm wrong but on late
kanasaka they had a lot of areas that
where people could not use the water
because the cyanobacterias can cause the
toxins it's not the bacteria but when
when the bacteria eat they eat
phosphorus they eat things that are in
the water and this is their excrement
that is poisoning people so I want
people to think about this on a
biological level you are swimming in a
lake that has neurotoxins that can hurt
you and this is not a lot this probably
strike down for this this is 25 million
dollars and when the bill gets on to
finance I think they will figure the
priorities but while we're here on the
policy I believe that we need to pass
the bill
representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman
and I just thank the sponsors for
bringing out this important issue I
think we we're the committee's in
agreement that it's an important issue
we've got to get it right again
representative ring and I agree that
it's a it's a critical issue for the
state to
get something done on cyanobacteria
even the commissioner says the bill has
some problems in fact they didn't come
out and support in fact they took no
position on it he says it right in his
testimony that the commission the
commissioner takes no position on this
bill
he states that there are some items that
are I quote could be problematic uh and
he says that one item that could be
problematic is the focus on loans and
that it's unlikely a Lake Association or
a watershed group could be in a position
to take on debt
thank you representative Vale for
bringing up the financial position
speaking of the financial issues we have
yet to hear the governor's budget the
house has yet to
deal with their budget so those are a
couple of issues that in the short term
perhaps we should wait to hear about in
the last session this committee passed a
bill to empower the department the
experts to formulate a plan and I don't
believe we've seen that plan yet so I
would love for this Committee in the
house
to see that plan and allow the
commission to in fact take a position
and give us their expert opinion on this
so we could get it right retaining the
bill doesn't kill it at all in fact it
gives us an opportunity to get it right
we support I think
bipartisanly a position to get it right
and do it right
not just Ram It Down The house's throat
and arbitrarily put a bad Bill the
commissioner says there are problems and
they didn't take a position I've never
seen a department head like a bill and
not support it
so I'm urging the committee to retain
the bill vote for retention and get it
right another
couple of months or a couple of weeks in
the budget process is not going to hurt
us let's get it right
representative wolf
thank you Mr chairman question for you
everybody says that it vote to retain
kills it until next year
my understanding is I can we can bring
it back
as representative McHugh said in three
four weeks or whenever
uh so to get it into this cycle we could
bring it back if Des has come ahead with
more recommendations we could bring it
back we don't have to wait till the
usual time of November to discuss it
again is that correct
I do not believe so
now I believe you can have to wait till
the summer to do additional
work on it or you have to you have to
wait to your other work is is completed
that's my understanding I could check
with the clerk of the house
yeah
it's my understanding no I think
retention means it will be worked on
but it can't be this it can't be you can
work you can work on it
but you can't necessarily you can't
have a
executive session on it until after the
you cannot have another executive
session is that correct that's my
understanding
but
I don't know I and I'm let me follow
so
one last question on it can we table
that motion for today uh yes I can
however that would mean
a table of motion for today I can tell I
would
yes I can table the motion or I can't I
can't I can I I can in in the discussion
on this right right now and bring it
back later however we would have to be
back here
Within
by next uh next week
to be the is the drop dead date on
hearing this
because it is an early bill
so
yes I cannot but I can I can find that
out
after we finish here I postponed this to
the end of the
uh
sort of the first break to be able to
find to find out to call the clerk's
office to be certain as to what I'm
saying
I guess that would then be my request is
to postpone it till you can get us some
answers on this okay I got I will do
that representative wrong yeah a couple
points one is Mr uh representative you
raised the issue about D yes it's the
only the only concern they raised is the
fact about the loan that some of these
associations may not I addressed that an
amendment that was just distributed and
I really want to make the point that
um this isn't just about Lakes
Recreation health of people in The Lakes
we have at least 23 Municipal Water
Systems that pull from surface water and
we have seen last year in the month of
May one of those was a victim of a
cyanobacteria bloom and that was in
Salem we also saw it in Bow and it's
only going to get worse cyanobacteria
especially after the mild winter we've
had so far there's
um nothing that prevents us from making
making a decision now I really urge the
committee to not vote to retain this
because it's going to be impossible to
get a bill to set up this kind of a fund
in the second year after the budget's
already been passed we have someone here
from Des who oversees the cyanobacteria
program I'm sure he would be willing to
speak about how this does not compromise
any of the work or would be impacted by
that plan that will be coming out in
November so if any of the committee
wants you know Mr chair if you want to
call him up and ask him you know how
does this interface with the work that
Des is doing on their cyanobacteria
Bloom I'm sure he'd be willing to offer
you know his his opinion
all right yeah you you used to speak yes
thank you um may I ask representative
wrong I do not have a copy of that
I don't think the amendment made it over
here either so here's your work yeah I
okay
all right uh
representative Veil
we didn't um anticipate a tabling motion
and so I would like us to walk people
through how that works there is no
there is no tabling motion allowed what
I can do as chair is I can recess or
make a phone call
to the to the clerk's office and find
out the answer uh representative Wolf's
question okay so rather than continue
the discussion without that knowledge
I will recess for
five minutes or as long as the phone
calls
since we're all here Mr chair could we
could you make that call at lunch okay
well let's make it pardon you just did a
recess to make it right yeah I just did
he says to make it now if I go he's
gonna he says I'm going to lunch okay
yeah lunch you had breakfast what more
do you want right I will make a phone
call to the
oh yeah
retained builds uh cannot work on
retained bills according to my
conversation with the clerk
you cannot work on retained bills and
Bill you've finished all of your
business
and uh in of of this year and so that
will
uh so
it's not a uh I think that
foreign
if we do vote retention it would not be
meet the
would not meet the the deadline that you
were speaking of representative well
so thank you Mr chairman I appreciate
your accommodating and asking that
question thank you Mr chairman
representative harb thank you Mr
chairman um with that knowledge and
information and knowing that we're not
likely to be able to get
um to review this until after budget is
set I'd like to withdraw my motion to
retain
thank you uh Court representative Horgan
would you uh I'll wait through all my
second representative with Morgan
withdraws his second their emotion now
on the floor is we don't have a moment
uh well we do have a lot to pass yes Mr
chairman
um should I submit the amendment first
or do the ought to pass first uh why
don't you submit the amendment okay
um I'd I'd like to move amendment number
2023.04 18h
to amend House Bill 276
.
did you actually make a motion to pass
I haven't introduced this yet no the
motion to pass oh okay so I move on to
well and then motion by representative
wrong second by representative Darby
second okay now I Mr chair I'd like to
submit amendment
2023.04 18h to amend HB 276
okay
for you
oh here it is okay
I used to speak to your motion yeah we
suspected the amendment okay I I believe
representative Darby yeah okay
um during the public hearing there were
two primary concerns
actually I think only two concerns one
was raised in a letter from commissioner
Scott that he he was concerned and it
was on the second page that their
um the financial burden of managing
problems within Waters of the state
holds in trust is shifted to communities
volunteer groups
um oh actually that's the wrong one um
he said it may be pragmatic because some
of these associations may not be large
enough to qualify for a loan so I
amended the bill to include a grant
aspect to it so
um Des when reviewing applications could
decide whether it should be grant or
loan and I used the current we have a
administration of the drinking water and
groundwater trust fund I based some of
that change on that so that's one change
so it could be a grant and it could be a
loan and it there still exists an
opportunity for loan forgiveness so
those are the three ways that projects
can be funded the other change I made is
on page
um two line
uh 17
um Mr chair you raised an issue about
oversight of of this fund so I included
the a duty of the Department of
Environmental Services is to
um Administration includes oversight of
the grant or loan expenditures to ensure
they are not misused
so those were the two issues that I
captured
um there were some very minor changes
there was one line where municipalities
was listed in one part of the bill and
not in the other so you'll see on line
23 I um municipalities are also
qualified to apply I mean they were
qualified to apply in another part of
the bill but I wanted to make it
consistent and I think there were just a
couple minor grammatical
issues but other than that the amendment
incorporates those two major issues that
were brought up and I do want to refer
back to commissioner Scott's letter in
the second to the last paragraph he said
as written HB 276 is targeted to fund
cost-effective and appropriate
cyanobacteria mitigation projects
he and his last sentence of that letter
is the plan will include many
recommendations this is the plan coming
in November some of which will without a
doubt include suggestions for
cyanobacteria Bloom mitigation
strategies including the resources
needed for implementation so the outcome
of that November plan will be able there
will be funds if this passes to be able
to implement those as well as other
projects that Des is considering being
submitted from municipalities lake or
Watershed associations so what this does
is it enables Des to address these
concerns in fiscal year 2024
without having to wait for another
biennium opportunity to get this in this
representative Darby to speak to the
amendment uh thank you Mr chair very
briefly I'd just like to reinforce the
value of the amendment in the um in
supporting the small Lake Associations
that
um are so numerous across our state
um we heard about that there was concern
about their inability because of their
low Revenue flow to be able to obtain a
loan on their own and this will this
will provide this amendment is critical
to being able to provide you know the
cyanobacteria mitigation for the
numerous numerous small lakes that we
have thank you
anyone else who helps us to speak the
question
for a question thank you Mr chair
um so uh representative wrong thank you
for
uh taking my question but uh the
original
House Bill 276 was alone
uh was based on a loan with a 10 for
forgiveness if I was reading it
correctly
and just to clarify this amendment
is 25 million dollars which could all be
grants
with no loan provision
they could possibly just
it'll be costing us 25 million dollars
because
Lake Associations don't have the money
is that correct
well it it could still be a loan I mean
for instance the town of malt or
Guilford
um Des could require a loan to mitigate
instances where there's runoff affecting
elukoya State Park or in that area but
for smaller associations
they could decide to issue a grant that
decision would be incorporated in
rulemaking
and I would expect that des and we do
have people here from DS that could
respond but in rule making Diaz could
um establish a threshold where
um a loan would have to be required
is there anyone else uh wishes to speak
seeing none
on the amendment
pardon oh I'm sorry I didn't mean that
they're gonna make you thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
bringing the amendment definitely an
improvement
and I look forward to seeing the plan
but uh definitely support the amendment
addresses some of the issues
that you mentioned from the
commissioner's letter
so along with representative wolf I
think we should probably go forward with
this amendment and finance will probably
work its magic a bit I suspect
but uh the policy issue we do support
medication of cyanobacteria across the
um I am also in support of this
amendment I think this addresses the two
areas that we heard about and um and I'm
hoping that with some of these
um Corrections and with this amendment
that we can get the pal bill passed and
send it down with a positive
recommendation on the floor thank you Mr
chair
anyone else on the uh on the amendment
foreign
for the amendment number number 2023
0418h
representative harb yes
representative Connors yes
representative Corrigan yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
wrong yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative franzula
no
uh now uh on the floor now is
ought to pass as amended does anyone
and I
think
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to um
say briefly that I appreciated Mr
McGee's comments uh representative thank
you's comments
um that I strongly agree with this as a
policy commitment from myself and
hopefully from our committee and that um
I'm happy to leave it up to the finance
committee to study further the financial
thank you Mr chairman I want to thank
you for moving us forward and for the
committee listening to the arguments on
this bill
hopefully you'll all vote for it and we
can pass it on to find it
to deal with thank you thank you
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
just a couple of quick points
um first off is we heard scary testimony
in my opinion from a number of Lake
Associations that had seen the first
cyanobacteria blooms ever over the last
two years so waiting two more years is
would be uh catastrophic in in my
opinion in terms of the number that we
would see across the lake
um we also heard that the
um the further that we delay in MIDI
that that these associations delay in
being able to mitigate their
cyanobacteria blooms uh the more the
costs increase so another reason that
you know I would
um urge that we vote ought to pass amend
with the amendment on this to you know
nip these costs in the bud while we can
um lastly
um my recollection from the uh from the
testimony with Des with respect to the
timing of the um the plan that they're
working on and the timing of these funds
is that these um the availability of
these funds would dovetail well with um
when their plan would be worked out so
that when it's when the plan is
completed in November
um the uh they would they would have the
funds available to start working with
municipalities and like associations and
lastly I just mentioned that the
um
the bill had overwhelming massive
support online
185 in favor and a handful against
this is an immensely popular bill
um across the uh across the state not
just with uh Lake you know with Lake
Associations and people that own
properties on lakes but also those that
are dry in the water from the um from
the surface water itself and some of the
scary
um you know situations that a
representative wrong mentioned earlier
so
um I would urge the uh you know that we
come forth with a really strong
recommendation at committee for octopus
thank you anyone else before I have my
peace
thank you
I will not be voting for this bill
all I know is that
last session
a bill came in
a bill that would have
had a study commission instead of
percent anal bacteria
and its study commission was going to be
for four plus years
and everybody was oh we really want this
you know every now those same people
say that we have to have this now we
must have everything we must the the
tidal wave is upon us well apparently it
wasn't upon us last year
because last year what we did when we
got that bill
we said four years is too much we feel
that the committee's failed that we know
cyanobacteria bacteria is an issue let's
do something really radical
let's ask d-e-s
to make a plan
to fix it
and the zes to their credit stood tall
and said yes we will
and with that I've I felt that
they should be given all the support
necessary to get the job done
well now we're Des is in the midst of
doing that they're doing a job but what
I see they're doing a fantastic job
moving forward
they the agreement was they would bring
something forward in November
and part of that they had they were
going to have this plan ready
and
now all of a sudden it's
we're back to the way we were before
just
turned throwing this football out there
and hoping that Des pass catches it
I don't know what to say folks
the
the job you're doing is great
I'm I'm sad that we're going to be
circumventing your
so
uh I'm late to see what your plan is and
not somebody else's plan
and you have to lift with it no I want
to live with your plan
with that
on uh
Hayesville House Bill 271
is amended
276 excuse me
that these get these new glasses these
old glasses will the flirt please call
the roll
yes thank you Mr chair on 276th
uh representative harp yes
representative Connors yeah
this is uh ought to pass what do we
pass ought to pass as amended no
clerk votes don't
representative Healy yes
representative wealth
yes
representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes
representative Vale
yes representative wrong
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative Hoyt yes representative
LaMontagne yes representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes
and representative frenzy Luke
no
okay
moving right along incense uh no it
can't be consent it's your money Bill
um
uh
thank you
thank you Mr chair
um
I recommend that we retain this bill
you want to hear a second
I'll second second by representative
harp
is to speak to your motion
um when uh the testimony was being given
by the by the different parties we uh
heard very good
um testimony about the uh the the
forward uh progress of what uh
um uh I'll say unmanned
whose drones is too limiting I heard I
learned during that testimony so
um but I think there's a lot that both
parties learned
um by talking to each other and I
actually uh think that they even agree
that there's more work to be done in
addition I know that there's been other
um
Parks across other
states that have done drone
um unmanned applying things
that they uh they actually have come up
with different plans so I think there's
an opportunity for uh some growth in the
the bill itself and working with
um both the uh the person that brought
it forward and the FAA
thank you
representative
echoing with representative Donnelly
said I'd just like to add that it's my
understanding the sponsor also
understands that the bill should be
retained so that we can work on it hence
any
representative fail
thank you Mr chair
my understanding also is that from um in
support of the bill in support of the
motion is that if we move to retain then
we'll have time to go to the Department
of Transportation and get some
instruction on some of the things that
we're voting on so that we know what
we're what the vehicle actually is when
we're talking about an unmanned aircraft
so I think this would give us time to
explore what we need to explore into
perhaps you know really anchor this in
some less abstract
um
and see it in person I guess is what I'm
oh
thank thank you Mr chair
um I I agree that this bill needs some
work I mean drones aren't even
identified in statute
um there were concerns raised by the
Department of Transportation and other
concerns the bill needs some work but I
want to be kayaking on my cyanobacteria
Laden Lake this summer and I am going to
vote against retention because I would
like the sponsors of the bill working
with the key stakeholders to come and
bring another bill in the fall and I
would be happy to put my name on that
bill but I um just personally it's I
don't like retained bills because it
puts all the work on us when I think the
when the bill sponsors are really
motivated to see something like this I'd
prefer if they do the leg work on it
so I'm going to be voting against
retention hoping that an itl motion will
follow and urge the sponsors to come
back in the fall with another an
I just have uh one thing that I I the
reason I will support this motion is I
would like to find out what the law
actually is around drones we have
the the
faa's or say in transportation saying
the federal government goes you know you
can take control all the air space and
then you have
the uh you have uh the the
Sparks people folks there they've got
rules and uh uh concerning this bill I
would like to have to have a retention
so we can be able to
ourselves know
what the law is
so that you know we we can all come to a
come to some kind of agreement that
this is this is what you can and can't
control
and that other than that that's why I
will be voting for it
I don't believe this bill will be uh
will get a positive vote as is
at the end of the uh of the
with that and he went
representative Lamonte yeah I would just
like to Second a representative rums
runs comments about this
um I think drones and
um
uavs are certainly something of the
future
throughout our whole society we're going
to see more and more of them but I don't
feel like as resources committee it's
our job to try to figure out the whole
big picture about that I think we're
here to protect the interests of the
state park and the um
the director of the park Association
wanted to see it not pass as opposed to
it and
um
I think we need to look out for the
interests of
that we can all enjoy the state park as
it is so I would be in favor of killing
the bill
the chair excuse me the vice chair
that's right here and you can learn the
uh Vice chair has reminded me that uh if
you if we hear if we uh retain the bill
uh the that kind of prevents the bill
from returning next session
however if we don't retain
the bill it can be brought back the next
session so
you may be hearing it again
I'd say but anyway that's a that is an
artifact of what of how how the system
operates
but that is any other question any other
comments any other questions if not
and a motion to retain will be
clerk please call the call the roll
er uh representative harp yes
representative Connors yes
representative four again yes
other votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wealth
yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
wrong no representative Kelly no
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne no
representative Lovett
yes
representative Ryan no
and representative from zulub
okay with
no that's right I believe we still have
four other early bills Mr chair we
skipped over 247 the one about the well
radii
that's not an early bill
Oh I thought FN bills were I'm sorry no
well
sometimes if they're less than a certain
amount
oh okay but uh you know just to be just
to be certain
it says March 16th all right
yeah the only way only early bills are
the only the other one the last of the
yeah
open the hearing and open the executive
session on House Bill 534 FN relative to
care records that recognizes
Mr chair
um I'd like to make a motion to retain
this spill and
I'll suck on that Mr chairman okay
oh do you want me to speak oh yes okay
um
that my concern is that this bill is an
expansion of the water assistance for
natural disaster impacts to low-income
residential well owners
um which was a fund um that is or was in
existence uh with the es
um the part that it is expands it as it
was this wand fund as it's called
um use was applying to applicable to
extreme weather events and this uh new
house bill uh is applying to any dry
well so I just have concerns that it's
an expansion of
the
representative harp you wish to speak to
the uh speak to the motion
I wanted to confirm I'm in agreement
with a representative of Howard Boyle
thank you
any else anyone else wish to speak
I won't be voting against the motion to
retain in order to bring another motion
forward
um if that one should fail and that's
because this bill is a critical bill for
people who are having difficulty with
their water and it is important to
address the fact that there are drought
elated and water emergencies happening
all over the state and as you can see
the result is that from the droughts is
that we have all types of problems with
um
invasive species and with what can be
going on with your well I sat with some
folks last summer who are legislators
and when we were talking about
um what's being going on during the
drought how it's been such a beautiful
summer and we hadn't had any rain yet we
began to talk about who's well ran dry
and who was getting mud coming up
through the pump so I think that we
really need to consider what happens to
people when they have this kind of an
emergency it really destroys the value
of the property and I would like us to
representative wrong for thank you Mr
chair
um I'm a little bit confused
representative Harvey bolio your
comments when you spoke to your motion
because throughout this bill it talks
about a result of damage to Wells as a
result of a natural disaster
um
so it has to be a natural disaster in
order for someone to qualify for funds
you know as well as I think there's an
income component to it as well so if
somebody's will just runs dry but it's
not a result of a natural disaster they
wouldn't be eligible for this funding am
I misreading something
and particularly noting the
um on line five of page
two or the page one I'm sorry line five
it the purpose statement mentions
natural disasters throughout it and also
the appropriation on page two line five
talks about that it's a natural
disasters fund and that's where the
Appropriations coming
so if someone just has a well that runs
dry this wouldn't this wouldn't apply to
them but I don't know if I'm missing
something
uh thank you
representative Ron
um I I believe it came out in the
hearing that it applies to any dry well
uh it does say
other acts of God which is
um on line six which is
fairly open to interpretation
um so that is where I took that
um
and there's we also mentioned in
committee I thought that natural
disasters is not defined
no
um
in a second Point
um if I may is uh
you know why why are we limiting this
fund to just
um for just people who have problems
with droughts and dry Wells when there
are lots of other people who have on not
non-potable water drinking water uh due
to too much rust or other contaminants
um
or just uh problems there's a variety of
problems I'm not really familiar with
them but I I do know um for instance in
my neighborhood that the water's not
drinkable because of rust so I'm not
sure why it's limited just the dry Wells
representative wolf did you have your
paint well if you shut set your
microphone off please
that's off
representative representative Darby
thank you Mr chair
um just a couple of points on line uh 28
of the first page which which is
actually the um you know the
specification of the rule not the
purpose statement it specifically States
you know natural disaster conditions and
conditions and locations are what are
going to be taken into account based on
the fund there's
um uh sorry based on this fund
um yes natural disaster conditions and
locations have to be defined by the
rules the um you know subpart 3 there
says that thick the commissioner has to
adopt the rules but that those rules
will be developed in an open Forum um
with that will allow for discussion
a couple of other points I'd like to um
to make is what I recall during the
testimony is that the fun the current
funds
um so so first off we should we should
be talking about you know who are the
people involved here the people involved
are you know the people that if they
lose their Wells if they if they can't
um they can't drink out of their tax
anymore they're they're um they're
beyond desperate um they they don't have
other options they're going to we heard
some testimony that suggested they might
you know have to relocate to
um more urban areas
um we also heard I recall that the this
is sort of a continuation of an existing
program that was bestowed by a by a
trust fund and those funds are used up
so if we don't pass this now what's
going to happen if we if we retain this
right even for a year there's going to
be a year gap before um before these
funds are available again during that
year Gap these what I would say is
desperate people are you know are going
to go without the last three years we
heard the last three years we've had
serious drought conditions and we don't
um and we also heard we don't know what
the conditions are going to be uh going
into next year
um we uh
um we also heard that there's no um you
know we
the rules state that the availability to
um
support this for the people that are
apply to support it has to be taken to
into account and that there's no other
sources femur acts even if FEMA even if
the um uh even if the federal government
declares and um not a natural disaster
uh the FEMA funds come in too late
um we heard that it's extremely
expensive to get an emergency well
drilled drilled and lastly I'll say that
um you know we heard Municipal support
because where do people reach out first
they're reaching out to the towns the
towns are reaching out to the state if
there's not a program like this
available
um that you know it it this the
suffering will be all the way down so I
I very much
um uh am opposed to retaining this Bill
anyone else switch to speak on the
motion
I guess I should put my two cents worth
in why not Scrooge Rides Again
at what point
does
People Are People responsible for
themselves
a well runs dry because the temperature
is too high
you can
you'll get
you'll get in these things and
the grass dies you can get a well
drilled which means you've yet it's not
just get getting getting
subsistence stuff subsistence that's
getting some Capital Money
significant money to build to drill for
wealth
sooner or later
people have to learn that they have to
live
you know on their their under under
their own
uh
by themselves live they're not I should
not be considered
getting
charities
not from the state the state
and this this is a significant Capital
Improvement I had no problem if the
state giving
maybe low interest loans
even a no interest loan provided the
money is paid back
or simply maybe even put on their
mortgage
to be able to have the state recover the
people's money
I mean we
we seem to be getting into a
situation where
the state is the is the insurance
company for everyone
and we can't be we just don't have
enough enough to do it
so I would I I could I could see
reworking this bill
to be able to
have
the people who are getting
a
substantial Grant singly by the just
that one home
it costs some money to
drill well and
it's not cheap
that they would have at least
the responsibility to be able to
pay back the loan
or even if you you pay back the loan on
uh as having this the states
money the the state's obligation or the
the or their obligation to the state
take preference over even their their
mortgage I don't mind I don't I would go
that far
but I'm not so certain I want to go the
this this this this this file
with the motion or against the with the
motion
not
clerk please call the vote
thank you representative herb yes
representative Connors yes
representative Horgan yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
no
representative wrong no representative
Kelly no representative Simpson no
representative Baldwin no representative
Darby no representative point no
representative LaMontagne no
representative Lovett no
representative Ryan no and
representative franzula
yes okay 10 to 10.
10 to 10. so promotion fails motion
failed
for a
or another motion
thank you Mr chair I move on to pass on
is there any second
representative Darby
you're you're fast
yeah tell a second okay Darby
thank you wish to speak to your motion
yes Mr chair thank you um
I think to keep it simple that we need
to know the true costs of a drought for
an individual who is a homeowner and for
other natural disasters that happen
where your house becomes uninhabitable
um and we have to think about the
thousands and thousands of dollars that
people have to pay and when they're
competing for a driller
in an emergency basis to put them in a
new well
and we have to be just like I said again
we have to think about what happened
last summer and how that affected so
many of the economic
things that happen in our state that
rely on water and an abundance of it and
this is one of those bills that will
help people to keep potable water in
their homes
in the event of an emergency thank you
you wish to speak to your second yes
thank you Mr chairman a couple more
points that I'd like to make
I'm first I um I took a gander again at
the State Constitution yesterday last
night and I was uh reminded of article 3
which says one of the key things behind
that we do as a as a society is to help
those in need and this clearly meets
that definition
um I'd also like to mention that
um the um the bill talks about a
continually appropriated fund because
this is expected to be an ongoing
problem I specifically asked about the
um the funding needed that was
appropriated in this versus
used by the trust fund and what we heard
is that
um they they need to have this much
funding up front to account for
um basically the unknowns that might
happen but they don't expect uh it to be
2.5 million a year over the last two
years they only spent 2.5 million total
so the um the the amount appropriated
here over two years which I I believe is
5 million is not to be expected I would
um anticipate would not be expected
moving forward
um uh and
um the last thing I'd mentioned is that
the bill itself is a bipartisan bill
um including um our representative our
own representative Gould who
unfortunately couldn't be here today
um so this is not uh this is not a
partisan issue this has got bipartisan
support we want to help the members of
our state and I'd urge you to uh vote to
pass on this thank you
representative rock thank you Mr chair
um I want to Echo what my colleague from
Nashua said about the bipartisanship of
this bill I mean the prime sponsor is a
another colleague of mine from Merrimack
and we see a colleague from
um Bedford and and Senate support for
this and I think what's important of
this is
um if these Wells don't get addressed
um when there's an unexpected natural
disaster it's going to hurt the property
value and we saw with testimony from the
New Hampshire Municipal Association how
important it is to have this program to
continue this program in order just to
maintain the property values and thus
the property tax is paid by that
property because if if someone is low
income and they their well is ruined or
in disrepair because of a natural
disaster
and they don't have the ability of the
funds to help them replace it or repair
it they're not going to be able to stay
in that property you can't have property
without water and they're going to leave
and that property value is going to
plummet and so will the tax revenue so I
think there's so many reasons to support
anyone else wish to speak down the
motion
seeing none
an emotion to retain uh yes
oh excuse me
motion ought to pass
the court please call the rules
all right
thank you Representative harb no
representative Connors no representative
Corrigan no the clerk votes no
representative Healy
no
representative wolf
yes
representative McHugh
no
representative Donnelly no
representative Dunn no representative
Vale yes
representative wrong yes representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative renzulu no
okay so that's 11.
I'll still 5 34 FM passes
who made the motion for that
representative Vale you will write the
report
Smith calendar now
11 to 9. I don't think it's a consent no
these are good
okay
all right that's the last of the uh
Finance of the early bill
well that was painful okay let's go for
I'm just gonna try to maybe go down the
list from the uh
that was
relative to waivers for Alternatives
representative
Mr chair I move to retain house bill
186. motions early to retain 186 uh is
second by representative Kelly
uh we wish to speak on your motion uh
representative Vale
yes Mr chair thank you um
so we had the representatives from
Grafton County come and say that the
taxpayers are paying 25 percent of their
County budget
um secondary to difficulties that
they're having with the sewer company
Municipal Association des and Grafton
was part of
a design that this was not a part of
so I think the best thing to do would be
to retain and to gather some more
information about this bill but also to
see if the people who brought the bill
forward can find some relief by working
through
the difficulties
that they are having in Grafton County
and and to be able to um resolve that
with a non-legislative solution
thank you Mr chair
anyone else wish to speak to the motion
representative Rock
even though I stated earlier my
philosophical opposition to retention
because I don't want to spend my Summers
here no offense to anybody but the
sponsors did indicate that they've been
having a continuing dialogue to improve
this bill so I do support the retained
motion
anyone else
okay
we all are
I'm getting older that's unfortunately
uh is there anyone's that's seeing no
one else
uh over the clerk please call the roll
to an emotion to uh retain retain
nice thank you very much 186.
representative Harbor yes
representative Connors yes
representative Morgan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh
yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative foyt yes representative
LaMontagne yes representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan
yes and representative yes
20 to zero
20 to zero it was close it was close it
okay
no you don't need to be on consent
calendar that's retained oh that's
retained retained 194 we've retained
uh 205.
House Bill 205 relative to testing
representative
there
we have an amendment to that bill and
wondering if we should move on to pass
actually all right you can move on you
can move off to pass move off the pass
first and then I immediately go into the
amendment so
uh just you know
this uh uh you know we want it's ought
to pass if that's what you wish
yes ought to pass is my motion thank you
okay all right and then Mel do you have
oh yeah second second
okay then then
it's an amendment yes so I'm passing
around the amendment oh yeah sorry I
thought I said yeah sorry he gave me a
nod
oh sorry
I'd like to make a motion for an
okay
oh and thank you sorry
see
I guess everybody go
shooting
all right is let's have a look at the
amendment why don't you explain the
amendment uh sure so first off
um
House Bill 205 and House Bill 398 are
very closely related they both
um contain similar language for
um notification for pfas House Bill 205
has a water testing component component
and House Bill 398 has a disclosure
component
but there's very similar language with
respect to pfas notification
um
what I'd really like to propose here
is that we have a work session on 205
and 398 together because I have another
amendment for 398 and I think we might
want to discuss how the two are
interlinked and what's the appropriate
Amendment uh what's the appropriate
remedy for both but I'll speak to this
amendment Standalone at this point
um what I what this amendment does is it
um we we heard
um pretty clearly that pfas is is having
significant
um impacts in certain parts of the state
but not significant impacts in all parts
of the state
we also heard that back in 2019 there
was unanimous support for a water
testing of new wells which according to
the criteria of
um subpar you know 42 b19-4 this this is
basically taken directly from the
amendment that passed with unanimous
support out of uh our r d in 219
passed through the house on consent and
then was tabled because of covet in the
Senate
um so this basically follows on to that
what we heard the pushback about the
um the pfas
testing in the original 205 bill was
that not everyone needed not all
locations in the state and not all areas
um and not all homeowners would want the
pfas testing
however there are some areas that it's
clear that the pfas testing is required
um we also learned that there are tools
available
um to uh for example on on the web Now
by Des that can tell you where um
where the
um you know where these pfasts
contaminated uh sites have been detected
of course that doesn't tell us
everywhere in the state where pfas is it
just tells us where they've tested for
it so what this amendment does is it
combines the bill from the 2019-2020
session for well testing with another
part that says if you are within 500
feet of a
um of a known pfas contamination site as
as that Des knows about oh and there's
that's what the the line 24 on page 2
talks about is how they would provide
and in my I spent a lot of time with
this tool my strong opinion
um with minimal training someone can use
the tool that's already available to
meet this exact requirement
um then the pfas testing would be
required and if the pfas testing so so
just to be clear that's in a limited
part of the state where we where there's
demonstrated pfas contamination
if the pfas testing is performed then
that result the pfas report would also
um be sent to Des so then they could
further update their database
this because in my opinion
the the notification and
um disclosure portion of the real estate
transactions are different from well
testing for new wells that's why I
pulled those pieces out and have an
amendment to 398 to support those
now
are you before we start going around I
are you requesting a
work session on this bill and
uh 390
now you realize you know these days I
have these have to be done by uh by
March 26th so we gotta go
16 16th so uh we got it
get the get it done and done it out
I'm I'm I will I'm happy to put forth
these two you know obviously everyone
has this copy I'll send out the other
copy we can do some maybe you know have
some
um some ideas on how we want to proceed
and maybe
I mean work sessions are my call of
course
um
what up
I I well I got a choice to do that
or we retain
uh because you've got a lot of stuff
I will I think I'll go with the work
session but
I wish you had given it to me this
morning
I could have got the thing in for next
week next week we don't have we're we're
did anybody have any issue with a work
session on this by the way if the it may
very well be the on March 8th we are
doing
the uh the speed limit on Winnipesaukee
in the afternoon so the work session and
a a uh a hearing will be on this one
and on
uh and on the uh the the uh Timber
we have to do a work session on that as
well
so
if I can get if we can get it if I can
get it in earlier we'll have them
earlier
but that's about that's the best I can
see is a calendar I know there might
very well be a uh a session called
for a
borrow Wednesday too so I have to work
around that so at any rate
we we do have I think we do have space
for the work session
so I'll call it so I'm just going to
postpone any more discussion on this
bill
uh 398.
all in agreement well everywhere
eventually agreement this is what I'm
going to do
you could tell me what you want later
yes uh representative Yeah question Mr
chair are we
um you're not going to plan that during
school vacation week right
do you think the last week of February I
hope not okay
because if you do you'll miss me blame
all right yeah that was I needed another
one guy I forgot about that but anyway
all right yes
uh Mr chair just for clarification so
the motion on the floor was ought to
pass with amended so we've decided to go
with the work session what happens to
the motion that we have on the floor
right now uh work session will it won't
come
the
but just to be just to uh
make it clean I'd ask for a uh someone
to withdraw their motion
I withdraw my motion for ought to pass
withdraw my motion for Amendment thank
you
watching my back thank you very much for
the work session Mr chair
all right where are we at now uh two two
and
representative Ron you're writing the
blurb on 212.
how are you okay
yes yes Mr chair and uh
okay
oh that's yeah
I make a motion of ought to pass on 214.
well should have ought to pass on 214.
recommended by representative Rome
uh do you wish to wish to discuss uh
um
yes I my understanding after the hearing
is that um this
simply updates the language so that
municipalities as well as Des may have
more flexibility and how they address
water quality issues
right now uh Mr
we should speak on your second
uh I I support
um on to pass on this I think we had
this discussion resources had at the end
of last term and uh this is something
that has broad supported updates
obsolete language so I it's deserving a
okay
seeing no one else for discussing
from the clerk please call the roll on
214.
thank you representative harp yes
representative Connors yes
representative poor again yes clerk
votes yes representative Healy
yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Bale yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan Yes representative franzulu yes
it's 20-0 lost from passes chairman I'd
ask consent uh yeah that's is that
okay
on consent uh chair is going to declare
a uh lunch recess for say just a half
that's even better but uh but I'll I'll
okay
so we got 11 to 9 here on this one yeah
so
so we're gonna have a minority
that was the ATM this is this is oh this
is
thank you Mr chairman I move that we itl
592.
there's a motion to itl 592 which is
relative to buffers around Wetlands is
Ed by representative Ryan
recorded by representative Ryan would
you
speak
it's on
I said you can go longer as you said
short in Sweden well okay don't stop for
me
all of the correspondents that I've
gotten says that this is an issue that
should be handled locally local control
and I'm not one to step on local control
um thank you yes
um this this bill interferes with
conservation commissions and their
abilities to monitor buffer zones buffer
zones in New Hampshire very anywhere
from 25 feet to 3 um 160 feet if I'm
going to build a 3 000 square foot
impediment into a 25 foot buffer it's
quite a bit big difference than building
it into a town that has a 160 foot
buffer let's let the towns do
um their own job thank you
anyone else uh speak to this
representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman I think anytime we
hear from the municipal Society
Municipal Association and the Audubon
Society both sing in an expedient
that tells you something
so I'll support the motion of
inexpedient to legislate
in favor of local control and supporting
the Audubon Society at the same time
thank you
anyone else have anything to say
I've been been dealing with Wetlands now
and and buffer zones or
all but
eight well for eight out of my nine
terms here
and it was always interesting that
that
the you had wetlands
uh
where was the what was where you know it
was the value the quote valuable land
because that was wetlands
but for always wanted to get
at
the
folks wanted to get at the Uplands
which is actually the usable land
and
but the only place where
the the only place in the uh
environmental statutes that we deal with
where where they're where they discuss
the buffer zones which is a Uplands is
then where whereas with uh
Prime wetlands
and not
anywhere else it happens this
well uh uh the the
buffer zones
which are but which is the good land
is handled in the zoning ordinances
and so
this bill unfortunately deals with
ordinances that we control which are the
uh you know the the wetlands the the
wetlands ordinances but the Uplands
the buffer zones
that's in a totally
separate
uh
totally totally separate uh statue
that's under the control of Municipal
and County
so
we have no choice
but to
find this bill ideal simply because it's
in the wrong place
so uh it's not that I'm against against
the bill if I were in Municipal and
County
but I'm not
uh
okay that is 592 FN on the motion of itl
this uh representative Barb yes
representative Connor yes
representative Horrigan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Don is not here
representative Vale
yes
I'm representative wrong
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative renzuela yes 19 yes zero
names
motion passes
19-0
yeah
build passes I mean yeah
representative wolf are you writing the
blurb or the no longer called blurb I
know
I mean they get the the clerk gets upset
yes sir I will write the blurb you mean
the committee report
I will also write that as well okay very
good
very good all right
uh yes I think it can
yep
for consent okay unanimous consent good
now they need 10 people to take it off
so
uh let's see how about
else Bill uh did we do about 488
I do House Bill 488 relative to State
Park campground reservations for New
Hampshire residents
and
that
thank you Mr chair I move itl
and a motion to itl on House Bill 488
okay motion itl on 488 is uh they're a
second
the second representative Darby
was to speak on your uh
on your motion Representatives Bale
yes Mr chair thank you
um House Bill 48 uh 488 which is
relative to State Park campground
reservations this would this would
enable the division of parks and recs to
allow New Hampshire residents a time
period to receive a state park campsite
prior to out-of-state residence but we
did hear that um
that as it is written this isn't
something that we can do because it it
um also
involves
it involves federal government because
of the fact that
any park that has even one feature that
was funded by federal dollars would
perhaps not fall under this
law so for those reasons
I'm I motion to IPL
right
representative Darby thank you Mr
thank you um
so um just uh piggybacking on what
representative Bale said um you know it
it's in conflict with the land and water
conservation act
um they also testified that it was going
to be difficult to implement with their
current vendor ticket vendor and would
require
potentially significant cost associated
with that and they've had they had a
prior issue in fact with violations of
the landing conservation act with a
and in no um because of those reasons I
I don't see a way to save this Bill
anyone else
I did get a phone call from uh the
sponsor
and uh
she uh
no okay so uh
yeah
with that on the motion for on 488 of
itl
and this but please call them
thank you
representative harp yes
representative
yes representative Oregon yes the clerk
votes yes representative Keely yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative done yes
representative veal yes representative
run
yes
representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative yes representative
LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative yes
20 to 0
okay House Bill 488 passives uh
okay for uh
CC
okay
all right let's uh
uh yeah
and
all right let's go back up to uh 247.
that was that was built 247 and then
all right
there recognizes representative Abby
bolia yes
um yes thank you
47.
um I would like to make a motion to itl
I mean uh no no no no no no no no no no
OTP I'm sorry we got the wrong one
um thank you
I'll second that
we've made in a sec seconded
okay and just speak to it um I'll just
say that house bill 247
uh fiscal note relative to protective
well radii clears up confusing language
about the property rights on any portion
of the protective well radius which is
not maintained on lot or on a recorded
easement and has some other housekeeping
features
um and it was uh
comes highly recommended
as clarifying this portion of the
Peach is there anybody uh I'd like to
just to comment that after our visit
with the Des and their explanation of
what they do and they are graphs about
well radii I certainly support uh
octopass
is there any questions representative
Darby not so much a question just just a
comment I
um I very much support the the um well
really everything in this bill
um especially the optimizations that it
will provide for the the well drillers
um the you know the lack of reducing
redundant paperwork that should reduce
costs and as it's been explained by Des
without any risk of
um of any loss of protection on um to
the the homeowner through the well
there's they have very good DS's very
good relationships with you know the
well drillers and the septic companies I
did have a question originally about
removing the reporting of the deed the
language that removes the reporting of
the deed because there I was concerned
that
um even though there is a website where
a potential buyer could go to
um to check the you know for example the
well radii that that wouldn't that might
not be obvious for a homeowner where
everyone looks at I think looks at their
deed before buying a piece of property
however after some discussions with Des
I realized I was informed that the
um if the well radii the protected well
radii goes on overlaps at a Butter's
property even if there's nothing
potentially dangerous there
they still have to use the protective
methods that we heard about from uh from
the well drillers
um and so I just I just wanted to state
that um any concerns that I may have had
about
um that recording of the deed have been
removed and I definitely support octopus
on this
that's bill 247. no way all of a sudden
this light came in over my shoulder I
figured
uh representative harp yes
representative Connor yes
representative Horgan yes click votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative wealth yes representative
NICU yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes
representative wrong yes representative
Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes
representative foyt yes
representative Lamonte yes
representative Lovett
yes
representative Ryan yes
representative renzullo yes
uh
yeah
requiring developers to secure hydrology
analysis which are certifying adequate
water capacity and potability when
building new subdivisions
representative
Healy
or emotion on this one I'd like to put
in an expedient legislative in
experience the legislate do I have a
second
second by representative harp
you wish to speak to your motion
while we heard on this one was the the
cost and the time frame to do this would
be extremely primitive to have the
something like this done
um costs were anywhere from fifteen
thousand up to a hundred thousand
dollars and then to drill all the wells
into all the testings they said it could
be anywhere from six to nine months just
not uh
acceptable when you're trying to do
representative herb you have to speak to
your second I'm just adding one thing to
representative Healey's comments uh my
memory is that they also talked about it
being a moving Target that you could do
this analysis one day and it would
change the next day because of changes
in the area so for that reason I support
Ito
okay
so anyone wish to speak to the to the
bill representative Rob
thank you Mr chair
um after saying that I'm against
retained bills I do recommend it for
this one just because I'd be willing to
to work on it but if you remember back
in 2018 or 2019 there was a bill that
came before this committee by
representative Mark Pearson and I
believe a representative Deb Hobson who
was on the committee was a co-sponsor
and it was in regard to the fact that
there was a community water system near
a near some houses and they were they
replaced their well and in the course of
doing that they ruined all the wells of
the neighbors and that bill passed
unanimously in this committee passed the
house on consent passed the Senate but
it died the coveted Death in June of
2000 and I really see that some of the
concerns that were in that bill overlap
with some of these not for the extensive
hydrology testing but the fact that
there needs to be some responsibility of
for people putting in new or replacement
Wells to ensure that those Wells do not
negatively impact or cause other Wells
to go dry
so I think this bill could really work
well particularly in context with that
previous bill I did speak to the prime
sponsor of this bill and she's willing
to work on that bill more to find some
common ground and the intent of
protecting other people's Wells which is
really what this is about it's really
protecting other people's Wells from
damage caused by new wells
and and find some commonplace I'm I'm
sorry I don't have it in front of me the
the bill from 2020. but do you remember
that bill oh yes I did yeah remember um
what the
the that was one of the bills that we uh
attached a
uh attached
having
uh co uh having uh uh pfas money
be put be given to uh homeowners that
was one of the uh we had there was
several
uh iterations of uh packing
things onto various bills and that was
one of the bills that that type of thing
got tacked onto so
okay
so um I'm gonna support again I know the
bill yeah
yeah because I when I went up and looked
at the bill history had been laid on the
table on I think it was June 6 whatever
that but I remember that day because
that's the day where a lot of bills
couldn't get through because they
required two-thirds to suspend the rules
if you look at that yeah so I'm going to
vote against the itl but willing to
support a motion to retain if the itl
does not pass
yeah
not
clerk please call the roll
thank you on the motion of itl on House
Bill 310 representative harp yes
representative Connor yes representative
four again yes click votes yes
representative Healy yes representative
wolf yes
representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes
representative Dale yes
representative rung no
representative Kelly no
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes
representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne no
representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan no
16 yeses to four no's
motion passes
foreign
passes uh 16 to 4 on
House Bill 310 itl
motion is
it is itl where you you will write the
blurb
are they committee report yes write that
too
Mr chair I'd I would like to re um write
okay
representative wrong
is your report going to be ought to pass
because we're not sure you can write a
report to retain
um I think I'm gonna
I haven't discussed this one with anyone
but what I'd like to do is defeat the
itl my report will be against the itl
but to support a floor amendment that
brings in the bill from 2020.
I don't know if I can do that
I don't know either but I gotta write it
on the piece of paper oh okay figure out
what to write down can I yeah leave it
empty for now
I'd like it like an otpa
um motion but on a but on a floor
Amendment I've already made one phone
call to the clerk I'm not making a
okay I put you down for OTP yet okay
there's a difference okay
and the next bill is we've done 397.
they're all the time they've done 437.
House Bill 472. I'd help the trees
Mr clerk Mr chair there's an amendment
yeah and I'd be happy to introduce that
oh Mr chairman I move a 472 an expedient
to legislate yeah
let's do will be I recognized him first
no I didn't
yeah this is we have do I added our hair
a second
second
472. Mr chairman can I speak my motion
pardon can I speak to that motion or is
this yes
go ahead thanks thank you Mr chairman
well I'll wait to the
um
I'll wait for the amendment to come
foreign
okay
let's see how to see if the light it's
the seat at the light is on
Mr chairman
okay
thank you Mr chairman so having a look
at this amendment
um
representative wrong you're offering the
amendment
um actually the amendment was drafted by
representative Crawford
um but um
she asked you know I told her I could
so I'll just speak to my motion um first
so my motion is in expedient to
legislate because the bill is drafted
um
would made it would make it impossible
for a landowner to even place a
temporary seasonal dock
on any of their land deemed impacted by
an endangered species under the
conservation act and as I see it now
fish and game has plenty of ways to
enforce
uh and penalties under 212a misdemeanors
violations and right now to get a
temporary seasonal dock you have to
notify the department and satisfy the 10
requirements that you see in the bill
and this bill adds a Prohibition
for that landowner so that you can never
get a seasonal dock if there's any
impact
to any Wildlife species or threatened
species
and and frankly doesn't really do
anything kind of like a speed limit side
does it doesn't prevent a speeder like
the person could still do it it doesn't
really protect
that wildlife
or that threatened species so I suppose
that's why the head of the doc
commissioner supposes the bill he says
it doesn't to remind the process and he
doesn't think it's a terribly well
written bill so I think as it is it's
so
in light of the amendment it appears to
limit it to only loons and only within
so I I still I still like this
find this bill in expedient to legislate
as it's written and perhaps there's
other thoughts on the amendment but my
as it is I'm not offering the amendment
so
representative harm
in support of the motion of itl even
with this proposed amendment
well the amendment hasn't no it's been
accepted to me it's Atlanta landowners
rights issue and there's 10 criteria you
have to notify the department and fish
and game has lots of enforcement
Provisions under 212a already
and
the expert on docs and Doc commission
opposes the bill we heard from him
we've heard from a lot of landowners and
a lot of Doc people and the temporary
doc seasonal dock thing has worked
pretty well and it's not going to
prevent anybody from doing
uh
what this bill aims to fix
anyways
you can speak to the mill you can speak
to the uh motion on the original bill
if this smell of motion fails I will
then bring in the original bring in the
the
emotion on the amendment and we will
then uh discuss the bill ought to pass
as Amendment
if if that if this motion Ito fails
so
thank you Mr chair so on the main motion
um for the reasons I already stated I am
not in agreement with the language of
the bill as proposed or the need because
of the other ability of Des to protect
Wildlife so I would support the itl
thank you
anyone else Mr Speaker Mr and
representative Darby been representative
Rome thank you Mr chair
um so that I definitely agree that
um as I've uh discussed in the um you
know in the original testimony that as
written it's too broad
um and the author
um the sponsor was uh willing and as
were numerous of the um the testifiers
um to to clarify the language in fact
there was many um I think all the
support that came back said otpa get rid
of the you know any wildlife
um
I uh unfortunately
um one of the um people that one of the
groups that we really needed to hear
from
um during that original hearing was not
available which was fish and game
um but I noticed um that we have the
honor of commissioner price from fish
and game here and I wonder if maybe we
could get
hey
on if this bill if there's any way
um if this bill really should be itl'd
or not
we're right in the middle
but maybe we could have motion can we
ask some questions uh in the middle of
the motion it's
uh I don't think so we're we're in a
voting mode
uh normally if if a questions before
uh or be before we went into a voting
mode or after
uh
we'll uh
I will I'll allow
going in on allow uh if if this defends
how this bill how this motion
if the passes or not well then
it will still wait don't uh
I know not not in a voting though no no
I don't think I'm uh just for my own
clarification uh Mr chair are there
opportunities at your discretion of
course where it's appropriate to ask um
clarifying questions from members of the
audience
if a clarifying question yes not
testimony
I I understand I I think I
misrepresented what I was asking I would
like to ask some clarifying questions I
are gonna have to call now I will call
it
are we
yeah we are at a voting mode I don't
think uh I don't think it's for I don't
to um then to conclude I would
um definitely vote against the Ito
um this this bill can uh is it's not
perfect but uh killing it for two years
isn't appropriate we heard it across the
board how
um how important this is uh to loons how
fragile uh loon nesting locations are if
you look for example on the
um on the Loon conservation commission's
website uh loon nesting locations are
not always marked intentionally although
they are reported to Des
and while this language is not is not
perfect it's definitely not itl worthy
actually
I have two choices
making a
when a voting mode starts
we we were not
vote we we were in this we were
discussing yes we it was before the
committee
I'm gonna have to reverse my decision
and say we are
you we're a voting mode we were not in
the count
that would be the voting vote no
I think I made an error so
I will let you ask a question
you know
of the
um thank you
um commissioner price were was there an
remember this is a question this is not
testimony right so I can ask when
they're ready if you make if I see
yes or no question
all right
um
uh thank you commissioner price for
taking my question uh I thank you Mr
chair
um
does the um fishing game have concerns
about the bill as written
uh yes we do
does fish and game think that the
language could be mended to make it um
to satisfy Fish and Game concerns
yeah
Excuse me yes it could
no I don't have any other questions
well since fishing game has no concerns
right
uh well they they were not here to
testify in
some Open Session
so that others could also
listen to what they had to say and and
had the had the ability
to counter what they said
correct
and my am I miss reading it
I mean
you know when the train leaves
you know it's unfair to those who have
to to testify here through
uh you know to add to answer
questions of their position
I I understand
um my my point
um is that
um as I so first I would I would suggest
that
um any testimony after
um you know testimony is always in order
and
um people that testify before a
subsequent testifier you know can't
comment on it so there's always an
ordering but besides that
um uh my the point of calling of asking
commissioner price this question
was not um to to uh ways to get clarity
on itl itl basically is uh because
there's other options in front of us
that we haven't considered yet other
motions
um and I wanted to get her position I
wanted to get the position on whether or
not the bill could be saved
um which is what I heard and there and
so I was trying I got my answer on
whether or not we should go to itl which
foreign
that is not no yes or no questions
aren't necessarily A
you you had a specific question a
clarification
that's well all that you can do in
executive session is to clarify and if
there's a get clarification
on something
you cannot elicit
new testimony
from uh from someone from the floor
during
the
that's
so that's the rules as I understand
but then again there's always like you
know and this time I'm not calling this
but
so
now I
your rights are you could challenge the
ruling of the chair but I bet you it's
i i i
Mr chairman are we taking testimony
Mr chairman are we taking testimony from
the Department in during executive
session yeah so is there additional
opportunity to ask questions or do we
no no of that you can that you can uh if
you're if it's a question or if there's
a player if you need a clarification on
they get they can
they they can
ants at they can answer
uh if if uh if I if I ruled that there
it's a clarification
and they and also that they wish they
would wish to answer they don't have to
answer well it may ask a question then
of the of the department as a forward
clarification for a clarification
clarification on the the statues that I
referenced earlier in my
my discussion
on their ability to enforce 212.
yeah I think you could you could see is
that and 212 is in the conservation act
that's referenced in and the bill is
written okay because I made some
thank you for taking my question
could you Enlighten us a little bit if
if somebody placed a temporary Dock and
they placed it in properly under
the endangered species conservation act
RSA 212a how would you enforce that
to protect under existing statute if we
didn't pass this how would you enforce
and protect the endangered species or
threatened species under RSA 212a what
powers do you currently have without us
doing anything we want to make sure that
we're there protected so yeah under
existing RSA
um we if if anything that that someone
does the results in the take of a
threatened or endangered species we do
have enforcement Authority
um specifically how that would play out
would depend on the situation but but if
we were made aware of a take which
there's a definition of in our rules and
I believe in the RSA we would have
enforcement Authority
thank you for making us feel better
about that and so if the itl passes and
a take would be something like if
somebody ran over the dock
thank you Mr chairman thank you do you
have a question on what testimony that
just
um yes I was just hoping you could
clarify what take means
um there's a definition of what take is
so it can be harm distress kill it's
it's fairly broad it's not just um it's
not just resulting in the death of an
animal so it it there's a quite a broad
definition of what take is
Mr chairman parliamentary inquiry
right
Mr chairman so if you feel comfortable
and agree with me
that there's significant protection for
these endangered and threatened species
currently in law and if you agree with
me then you would have vote would you
then vote with me and the rest of the
committee to find this bill and
expedient to legislate
parliamentary inquiry no that's not
thank you Mr chairman
call the question
no there's no calling of the question
and if
committee
representative Lamontagne
as I understand
the spell
if we
um say we're to include the amended
language
it's still not saying that someone can't
put a temporary Doc in it only means
that they have to get a special permit
they can't go through the exemption by
just notifying the department
they have to get permit and
I think
with regarding the other language
um
that fish and game could take recourses
for an injury that already happened the
intent of this bill is to try to prevent
the injury to the loons to begin with by
being more careful of where we put the
temporary dock it's not saying nobody
could put a docket
that's my understanding and that's why I
don't want to see um
the spell itl and I think it can be
saved
what else was just
testimony by anyone else
representative representative bailed in
thank you Mr chair I'll be voting
against a motion of itl um today I think
this is an important bill
um and I can tell you that
when the Audubon Society comes out and
wants to work with us to help with the
loons I'm always going to be one of
those people that really wants to help
them back and I think the language
change that was asked for during the
hearing
regarding Wildlife we had the New
Hampshire Lakes management advisory
committee
weigh in on that and I do believe that
the
the change in the language where loons
are a threatened species turning that
put using this amendment that were what
we're looking at is going to take care
of the language problems that that
anyone who was there might have had for
this I think I think this bill has Merit
and I I want to just reiterate that New
Hampshire Audubon and as well as the
Loon Society
prevent preservation committee and all
the people that have been working so
hard for for all of this time have only
been able to make so much progress with
the Loon population and we have a lot of
things that have come through this
committee over the past few months that
um really clearly show us that the
impact from the environment is
accelerating and the fact that we have
wounds we don't know what's going on
with them what their reactions to a lot
of the threats that they have but this
is a shorebird and we are protecting
where they nest and it's at a critical
time and if we don't move ahead with
this we won't be able to maintain the
population that we have now and so
that's my testimony in opposition to a
anyone else would accept representative
Brown thank you Mr chair
I'm also opposed to the itl based on the
amendment that hopefully I'll get to
introduce during testimony of this bill
and the public hearing the
the concerns raised by most of the
people testifying were that it was too
vague and it wasn't specific it would be
really subjective and to be able to
assess when an endangered species is
threatened but the con the specific
concerns that were raised by the the
people testifying had to do with loon
specifically and if we look at the
written testimony that was submitted it
was the same is true of the Lakes
management advisory committee The Loon
preservation commission and the Audubon
they all talked about the loons so that
was the impetus for representative
Crawford to bring forth this amendment
just to address that specific concern
and if you look at the letter by the New
Hampshire Lakes management advisory
committee of which commissioner price is
a member along with Bia and a very broad
range of people they that group supports
this amendment they say
um as a result we support the bill with
either two amendments one to allow
either allow permit exemptions when a
temporary seasonal dock does not affect
common loans so this is an amendment
that would allow that well it's the
converse is true this would be allowing
temporary docs that don't impact loon
nesting but it would prohibit temporary
docs from infringing within a hundred
and feet of a loon's nest so I hope the
committee defeats the itl so that this
amendment in an otpa motion can be made
thank you
anywhere else wish to speak
on the motion of itl
noticeable itl and the court please call
thank you representative harb yes
representative Connor yes
representative Corrigan yes uh the clerk
votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes
representative McHugh yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes
no representative wrong no
representative Kelly no representative
Simpson no representative Baldwin no
representative Darby no representative
Hoyt no representable maintain no
representative love it no representative
Ryan no I am representative
no
hey Bob you're supposed to go hit me
here have it
yes yes okay just know what I'm just
trying to keep you awake yeah
I was
motion having failed
is there in another motion
and if you have
yes Mr chair I'd like to move
OTP and then introduce an emotion
so the OTP would be on HB 472 and I
think that motion then I do the
amendment right okay
yeah
need a second
second by
Republican
so maybe that's a piece of paper
yep uh you want all right on the um the
first week we should
move on you want to move on the
amendment
yes
um yes I'd like to move Amendment
2023.0292h
is there a
is versus speak on your motion yes thank
you Mr chair as we heard during the
public hearing the concerns it raised
about the bill as introduced were vague
not specific but there was a lot of
concern about loons and so this
amendment drafted by representative
Crawford who was the Prime sponsor of
the original Bill Narrows that and is
extremely specific that temporary dogs
would be prohibited in areas that will
impact loon nesting or with 150 feet of
loon nesting we also heard from The Loon
protection
um hold on the Loon production committee
or preservation commission thank you or
committee that there is very very
specific procedures to identify where
these loon nests are and assign them GPS
coordinates so it really assists Des
with being able to pinpoint specific
locations where these docs may impact
loons which we all know are endangered
and they're a real icon of our state
that we should protect that data goes to
the National Heritage and it sets those
coordinates so I think the concerns
about vagueness and
um
broad terminology when we talk about
threatened species or endangered species
is addressed and solved through this
amendment so I would encourage the
pretty much thirst anyone wish to speak
to their second
thank you Mr chair
um
I'm never going to miss an opportunity
to tell you what I know about loons
and I hope to get everyone in the room
on the Loon Cam over the summer when the
nests are out there and I can tell you
that what the Loon preservation
committee has done is that they have
identified nesting areas where
they're not
able to support a natural Nest any
longer because of changes in the
shoreline or changes in what is going on
in those buffer zones that are that are
just close to where the birds nest
um
as you may have heard or as you may not
have heard loons are
a bird that spends most of their life on
the water they don't have legs for land
they have legs that swim and they swim
fast and they dive and they fish and
they feed their family
for a lake to have
Looms on it
means that there has to be food in the
lake there has to be
the kind of environment that would
support them and in the places where
there is no longer an environment that
supports a pairing a loon pairing in
their nest
what they do is they put out a nest
that's on a raft and those nests are
followed as well and that couple has a
better chance in a territory that is no
longer going to be viable because
there's been a failure of a nest year
after year
loans only give birth to two eggs
and so it's a really big job for the
parents they have about 24 hours to get
those little ones
to stop picking on each other and to eat
and they spend the rest of their life on
the water so we're we're talking about a
short amount of time when the moons
begin to nest and when they begin to
incubate and once the hatch is
is taking place
um
they would leave and it would be okay
for a person to put in their temporary
dock or to do whatever it is they need
to do to their temporary doc that
couldn't be done during the nesting
season
so I support you know I really think we
need to pass this I think we need to
recognize that loons are a sentinel and
Environmental Quality and that is
something that you would learn if you
spend some time at the Loon preservation
committee and the health of the Loon is
very indicative of the health of other
wildlife and of us as beings in New
Hampshire
so
basically what we want is not asking a
lot it may be asking a lot of one
property owner but where one pair of
loons
takes up so much of of the territory
that they need to have food they need to
have
um
they need to be able to survive on that
Lake it needs to have a brooding area it
needs to have
um
just the one pair of looms and they are
very territorial this is there it's not
about a romance although you say see the
same pairings year after year after year
it's about the survival of wounds coming
from that territory and loons are so
driven to go back to that same exact
spot that we need to make sure that
those places are available for them to
come
to have a Loon Lake with no wounds on it
is not something that we want to see we
want to bring the loons back to the
Lakes where we know the Lakes have
supported them in the past and we want
them to be able to flourish there and to
recover and as we as time goes on
when an elderly loon dies or no longer
begins to you know no longer nests then
that the replacement of moons in the
population in order for them to try to
restore the populations that we
previously had is very painstaking
process
I don't think it's a huge inconvenience
to people with a temporary dock to
postpone their work or to relocate it
and we are talking about one doc on a
small Lake and maybe many docks on a
very big lake but in most of these areas
there's a Loon Lake there's only a
couple of pairs at the most and we
wouldn't want to discourage that and so
I wrap up my testimony with that thank
representative Donnelly or
coming thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Vale for your uh
information
um I'm very uh close to our loons we had
a loon on our uh Canobie Lake we named
him champ we've had him for we had him
for 20 years
um so we specifically have been working
with the Loon preservation committee uh
as the Canopy Lake protective
Association and I'm the president of
that Association for many many years and
so yes I have a great deal of love for
the loons absolutely champ had passed
this past year because of the and they
did actually nest and they they produced
two eggs and then they abandoned the
nest because a bald eagle actually
attacked them so loons are very
interesting I mean I'll be honest I mean
I'm on the lake they're not scared of
people they're not scared of boats on
Canopy Lake you literally can drive
around they'll come up right next to you
depends on the lake so one of my uh you
know cautionary tales with this with
Amendment specifically it talks about
150 feet for small lakes you're now
affecting I don't know how many homes
that suddenly won't be able to put their
dock in because there may be a loon Nest
that's near that particular area
maybe 50 feet but this is way too
extensive of of a territory that that's
been randomly picked I don't know if
there's any studies that talk about why
150 that I'm aware of balloon
preservation I recently supported
um and we supported two rant I am two
rafts that were put in one was next to
my home which would which is closer than
150 feet and if they were saying hey
this would be a problem for you to keep
your Dock and your boat here Tanya
you're going to need to move this I
probably would have relocated that Nest
to another spot but this is a very nice
secluded area it works well they
frequently come unfortunately a mallard
took over last year that particular nest
so as far as a lot of the testimony you
shared I I agree wounds are are are we
all love them we want to keep them
um however we need to understand this
particular Amendment could impact a
great deal of people's property that we
have no idea what we're impacting by
just passing this
um and saying yes this is what we're
going to do we could be affecting some
tourist territory we could be I mean uh
homes and other areas of of information
so we need to be careful about this
amendment because it's way too
restrictive in in Feats and time um an
just said I too will be voting against
the motion out to pass as amended um I
think that this committee should retain
the bill I think that there's obviously
some
um we could use some more insight from
fish and game
um I I am concerned with some of the
language in the amendment
um I don't know if it has a time limit
on the nesting
um we talked about how nests move
um and so the idea that if it's a
nesting area one year is it protected
the following year because it was used
as a previous Nest I think is something
that the committee should explore and
hope you come out with something that
that does protect the uh balloons
or of course he's the maker of the
motion
thank you Mr chairman thanks for
bringing the amendment it definitely
makes it a better Bill narrowing it down
to loons
so I've heard from a number of
landowners one is one of my best friends
and mentors throughout my career who's
retired up to Madison to Silver Lake and
and built a home on his family property
and he's introduced me to the lovely
loons there and sent me pictures every
time they nest
and he has a um he's probably watching
now he he has a temporary dock that he
rolls in and out and he's very careful
to put it nowhere near the loons but he
doesn't have 150 feet so he'd be
impacted and it's a small one of those
docks with the the Rolling Wheels it's I
mean it's no bigger than one of these
little committee tables so he'd be
impacted and he's the most
conservation-minded family teaches his
kids he's was brought up in it his Camp
is over a hundred years old
um so my concern is 150 feet and I'm all
for protecting the loons and for the
conservation and I'm glad the bill is
narrowed from any endangered species or
any threatened species that's the way it
should be it has to be a balance between
protecting the species
and considering existing law and not
passing laws for the sake of passing
laws
and letting our state departments do
what they're empowered to do and
protecting landowner rights so the
question is how do we how do we do both
and I'm and I'm not sure that 100 so 150
feet is is a lot of places in Marine law
you know 150 feet away from another
Craft Jet Skis 150 feet away from
Shoreline to prevent erosion that's
where I think the 150 feet may have been
plucked from because it's many places in
Marine law and in and in lakes
so I don't I don't know where the 150
feet came from I'd be interested to know
and I think passing something is
probably not a bad idea
so a work session or retaining maybe so
I'm asking the question I'm throwing it
out there so I'm not entirely against
but maybe not this exact thing so does
somebody know where the 150 feet came
from
actually I think we probably have people
who might then that is a legitimate
question because 150 feet of Shoreline
is a lot uh I mean that's not to make a
uh
I did check well first of all before I
ask you the question I did check with
someone
and and
Des on this on where 150 feet comes from
and they don't know
okay is there yeah so you
is what statue does have with those 150
feet it's in many places I know in
Marine law to stay away from the shore
from another boat a lot of places that I
know of but about from for this specific
I don't know where that is but I
couldn't find it in two one two a
so where is the 150 or the for this one
yeah it's not in RSA 212a
um there's no distances there so I'm not
I'm not exactly positive where it came
from
uh it did I spoke to representative
Crawford about the narrowing it to the
loans I knew immediately I live in
moultonborough I'm in Loon Central I
spend a lot of hours on the lake both
paddling in on a power boat
um so I guess I'm testifying but uh just
to give you backstory I had talked to
her about narrowing it to the loons this
was an issue the commission had with it
uh which is why we initially opposed it
for the same reasons
um and so I actually don't know where
the 150 came from in her Amendment
because she and I did not discuss
Mr chair I don't know where it came from
either I representative Crawford just
sent me the amendment but I
um from the discussion in the sense I'm
getting I would be happy to withdraw my
motion and have us pursue either a work
session or retain the bill so that we
can make sure that it is effective in
protecting the loons while respecting
Waterfront owners
okay does anybody have a sense
um
like how much is enough and what what do
people have Waterfront wise
uh we I think well I guess 75 feet maybe
the subject for a workshops it's 75 feet
enough and do most people have
100 feet of beach I don't I don't know
maybe that's a work session discussion I
representable if we're looking for
clarification on 150 feet and I know
that's a lot of the Marine rules can I
ask the department if they have a
okay I I apologize yeah because
yeah either either work session or or a
trouble is or pegged we're backing up on
work sessions now folks yeah right uh
a
retention would might be better we
probably get we can actually go out and
well follow up
Mr chair if the maker of the first and
the second on the amendment and the
first and second on the main motion
withdraws both motions I'll make a
motion to retain
I withdraw my motion to introduce the
and I'll stick around here any second I
would have made and I make a motion to
retain thank you both
I'll entertain emotionally
thank you very much
yes definitely
all right
Mr will representative one do you want
wait am I am I seconded
oh there he goes yeah now he could no
excitement
all right you have a motion
I have a motion to retain we have a
motion to retain a nice second okay
representative wrong with seconds any
well seeing none will the clerk please
call the rule gladly
with relish but representative herb yes
representative Connor yes representative
Oregon yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf yes
representative yes
representative Donnelly
yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative wrong
yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes please
and representative franzula yes now why
was that so hard yeah
20 to zero
okay but to retain do we have any more
stuff yes we're we're done okay uh when
I need
I need all of the
committee reports in
uh
I think
I've
I'd like to get them I like to get them
into me by Monday
Monday okay yes Democrats to
representative Vale by whatever she asks
for them but I want them on Monday
because I got to get them in I got to
and just get them to me by um Friday at
five o'clock if that's okay
and by the way we will be setting up
we're going to go right over now and uh